when you look at the history of the
world
as you have done in your new book
principles of dealing with the changing
world order
what is more important more impactful
money or power
they go hand in hand
they support each other and they um
compete with each other
those who have money have power a
certain type of power
um that power
has to do with all that they can buy but
it also
has the ability to influence those with
political power
so
um and and so you see this throughout
history this symbiotic relationship
you know um for example between
um
the royal families
the nobility
and the church
so you see that group of people
supporting each other in various ways
and then wrestling around with each
other
for the money and power among that group
so the dynamic that's quite classic is
you could look at
the parties in power
back in you know the
16th 17th centuries you would look at uh
royal families nobles and
and
the church if you're in europe and then
you would look at
agricultural land
and there was a certain dynamic
and that varies over time it changes
as those people get thrown out and
technology changes so when we
evolved when the society evolved so that
it would produce goods and services
and you have something like the
industrial revolution the first
industrial revolution you have machines
and you have the talent of people that
are off the farms
and then you have a struggling for power
you see that power mix change
and so we don't see that same power mix
anymore but you still see the same
dynamic
you see those with money
dealing with those who have
political power
around those assets that are considered
most valuable to particularly the
productive assets that produce money